[Música]
cuántas veces se han sentido tan
terriblemente imperfectos en una
sociedad de perfección es tan fácil ver
los mejores momentos de nuestros amigos
conocidos famosos e incluso de nuestra
edad pensar que si bien en toda su vida
no hay problemas solo éxitos relaciones
perfectas cuerpos perfectos momentos
chidos de los que nos formamos parte
vidas perfectas más que nada y eso nos
hace preguntarnos por qué soy el único
que no se siente bien todos los días
porque no soy tan atractivo como las
personas a mi alrededor
porque no tengo la pareja
la vida
pero más que nada porque soy tan
imperfecto
estas son preguntas que se hace la
juventud de hoy en día cosas como el
formó o miedo a perderse las cosas el
fácil acceso a filtros y el photoshop la
forma en que están diseñadas estas
aplicaciones pero sobre todo el
compararnos con otras personas nos ha
hecho sentir como si estuviera mal ser
imperfecto entonces mostramos la cara
perfecta al mundo no hay imperfecciones
en nosotros ya la gente le gusta eso
pero le gustamos nosotros las personas
imperfectas con vidas imperfectas o les
gusta la cara que ven
quién soy yo para decirles esto soy jose
ángel rendón lópez mejor conocido como
pepe reloj nací en 1996 y por muchos
años era el niño perfecto buenas
calificaciones consentido por mis padres
popular en la escuela
en realidad no era perfecto me
diagnosticaron con déficit de atención a
una edad muy temprana con estudio
cerebral y cito
mis padres se divorciaron a mis 8 años
entonces dejé de ser el niño consentido
para ser el niño mensajero dile a tu
papá dirá tu mamá
tuve que tomar la hormona del
crecimiento en mi pre pubertad
y cuando pase a secundaria los mismos
compañeros que como siempre escolar y
primaria hicieron bullying tuve que
cambiarme a una escuela donde no conocía
a nadie y no podía ser enteramente yo
porque si siendo yo con las personas que
conocido ante 10 años las cosas salieron
mal imagínense con personas nuevas
me volví tímido e introvertido 2
pero mi mayor error sin duda fue
aferrarme un concepto de infancia que no
existió para mí una infancia exagerada
con conceptos que venían de caricaturas
o películas para lidiar con los cambios
hasta que un día mi hermana querida usó
mi amor por los videojuegos en una
metáfora
y de juegos como super mario que tienen
una historia definida y niveles con
dificultad variada pero que se van
haciendo progresivamente más difíciles
al menos en un buen juego un juego bien
diseñado
la vida es más o menos así solo que la
historia la vamos escribiendo en cada
nivel
entonces ella me dijo imagina que te
quedas en un nivel por miedo a lo que
venga en los siguientes sería divertido
por un rato dominas ese nivel no hay
retos
pero va a llegar un momento en el que te
vas a aburrir no vas a avanzar
no vas a lograr el objetivo del juego
que salvará a la princesa
en cambio si sigues con los demás
niveles quizás te equivoques pero puedes
intentarlo de nuevo con una nueva
estrategia o quizás incluso tomar otro
camino y tendrás experiencias en niveles
que te emocionan
que te sorprenderán
por favor pp atrévete a crecer
y desde ese momento decidí crecer crecer
imperfecto pero crecer
y gracias a eso logré entrar la carrera
que quería hacer el servicio social en
un lugar que me fascina
y logrado ser mi primer videojuego en
tan solo tres días y presentarme en una
noche de micrófono abierto con mi propia
rutina de estando
y muchas otras cosas que para el chico
tímido inseguro hubieran sido imposibles
y empecé a mis 18 años 18 años
por eso creo que cualquiera puede crecer
no importa su edad o la condición
sin embargo la decisión de crecer es una
que se toma todos los días y unos
niveles son más difíciles que otros pero
aún así cree en el poder de crecer cada
día
en este momento les voy a compartir lo
que ha funcionado para mí en este
proceso de crecer imperfecto
primero está aceptar que soy imperfecto
no soy no fui y no seré perfecto así
como nadie aquí lo será algunos les
mostrará la idea
pero digan
qué es algo perfecto algo sin defectos
algo que tiene todas las cualidades
requeridas o deseables que es muy
adecuado para un determinado fin pero
sobre todo algo que no puede mejorar
qué pasa con lo que no puede o deja de
mejorar se queda atrás en este universo
cambiante el universo no es perfecto si
fuera perfecto el sol la tierra y todos
los planetas hubieran existido desde el
principio
y no el universo crece todos los días ha
sido así durante miles de millones de
años creciente y así como nosotros y el
universo en el que estamos no somos
perfectos tampoco son las cosas que
creamos renunciamos a la perfección una
vez oí una frase que decía es mejor
hecho que perfecto
y como ejemplo de ello tengo el
videojuego que hice en tres días aquí
está una pequeña foto de cómo es no
tiene los mejores gráficos o una
historia grandiosa simplemente un mago
defendiendo el santuario de un palacio
mágico de un grupo de magos que lanzan
cráneos de fuego ni siquiera tiene
sonido música o forma de pausar lo
pero lo hice
hubiera hecho algo mejor de tener más de
tres días definitivamente de hecho estoy
trabajando en él pero lo hice
hice ese juego
no estoy diciendo que no apunten al 10
háganlo
pero si sólo pueden hacer ese 1 háganlo
de todos modos un 1 es mejor que un 0
siempre
y quizás incluso se sorprenderán de lo
que ese uno les ayude en su crecimiento
imperfecto
el siguiente paso está en conocerte a ti
mismo
conócete a ti mismo es una frase que
dijo un hombre muy sabio que conocí en
la preparatoria y seguro ustedes también
lo conocen su nombre solventes
conocerte a ti mismo implica verte
honestamente en el espejo física y
mentalmente ver tus fortalezas lo que
eres bueno pero también ver tus defectos
ver tus vulnerabilidades tus
imperfecciones observarlos detenidamente
y aceptarlos
para mí fue aceptar mis dientes chuecos
los granos en mi cara mis músculos
flácidos
el pasado que no me gustó los rechazos
pero sobre todo las oportunidades que no
tomé
y las ideas equivocadas que tengo de la
vida
después de aceptar los podrás corregir
lo que está en tus manos
quizás puedes hacer ejercicio ahorrar
para un tratamiento
y la terapia quizás pero así como un
doctor no puede curar una enfermedad sin
saber dónde te duele o en qué lugar está
haciendo daño no se puede corregir algo
que no haya sido aceptado aceptar es el
inicio del camino a crecer imperfecto
y el siguiente paso es renunciar a las
expectativas
cuando me dijeron que iba a dar esta
charla primero me emocioné bastante no
puede ser voy a estar en text me
aceptaron
pero luego se apodera una sensación en
mí sentía como si no lo mereciera como
si no hubiera hecho lo suficiente como
para parecer un speaker
a esto se le conoce como el síndrome del
impostor es un transtorno psicológico en
el cual las personas exitosas son
incapaces de asimilar sus logros y es
normal cuando empezamos a tener
resultados de crecer
pensamos que hay personas que se lo
merecen más o que debería de tomarnos
más tiempo no tenemos la preparación
suficiente para hacer lo que queremos
hacer
y sobre todo que vamos a decepcionar a
quienes creyeron en nosotros en primer
lugar
pero luego entendí que compararme con
otras personas solo me hace daño después
de todo las oportunidades que se nos
presentan vienen por una de dos razones
para probar que hayamos aprendido o para
aprender
he aprendido al perder la oportunidad
pero aprendido mucho más al tomarla
las personas suelen arrepentirse más de
lo que no hicieron que de lo que
hicieron
así que renunciemos a las expectativas y
tomemos las oportunidades para crecer
imperfectas
otra parte de renunciar a las
expectativas es no comparar con otros a
las personas que conocemos esas personas
también son imperfectas ven y nos va a
resolver la vida o va a ser la fuente de
la felicidad o va a ser la persona hecha
a nuestra medida de nuestras necesidades
nadie nadie ni tu familia ni tus amigos
ni tu pareja no hay que poner a nadie
ninguna clase de pedestal eso sólo
termina lastimando a las personas ya
nosotros hay que dedicar no solamente
hacer ya crecer
y por último pero no menos importante
tenemos aprender
así es aprender
yo estado del otro lado viendo y leyendo
toda clase de material que me ayudará a
entenderme vídeos libros charlas ted y
te decks parte de ese deseo de aprender
es lo que me trajo aquí
aprender es crecer podemos seguir
aprendiendo incluso estando lejos de la
escuela esto no es algo exclusivo de ese
lugar como ya les dije las oportunidades
vienen para probar que ya hemos
aprendido o para aprender
pero para aprender es necesario
equivocarse
todo el conocimiento viene de un error
no nacimos sabiendo caminar un gran
matemático no nació sabiendo sumar o
restar
y un gran escritor no nació sabiendo
escribir tuvo que equivocarse con la
gramática con la ortografía con incluso
los espacios
nuestros maestros inventores son
personas que pueden enseñarnos
precisamente porque se han equivocado
saben lo que no funciona pueden decirnos
he probado este camino y a mí no me
funcionó te recomendaría no ir hacia
allá
puedes ir quizás acá
e incluso si no estamos de acuerdo con
el maestro podemos tomar lo que es útil
para nosotros de hecho les recomiendo
mucho que lo hagan no ven el maestro
solo también su enseñanza
sin embargo al final del día nosotros
somos quienes tienen que cometer sus
propios errores vivir su propia
experiencia
y estos errores nos enseñan a
desarrollar nuevas estrategias para no
cometerlos de nuevo no cometan el error
que también yo he cometido de ganar
conocimientos pero nunca aplicarlos
aprendan todos los que pueden de la vida
prueben cosas nuevas y apliquen el
conocimiento para seguir creciendo
imperfectos sin miedo a equivocarse
porque equivocarse es aprender y
aprender es crecer
pues estos fueron los cuatro pilares que
me han permitido crecer imperfecto
quiero compartirles una frase que creo
que todos deberíamos de oír en algún
momento de nuestras vidas mi maestra de
preparatoria estando cerca de graduarnos
nos regaló chocolates con frases el mío
decía una de christopher robin en indio
winnie pooh la frase dice así
eres más valiente de lo que crees más
fuerte de lo que parece y más
inteligente de lo que piensas
eres más valiente de lo que crees más
fuerte en lo que pareces más inteligente
de lo que piensas somos imperfectos en
un universo imperfecto y de nosotros
depende seguir creciendo pero somos
valientes fuertes e inteligentes para
aceptar nuestra imperfección para
conocernos a nosotros mismos para
renunciar a las expectativas y para
aprender en este juego de la vida yo soy
pepe reloj y créanme cuando les digo que
no es tarde para crecer nunca lo es
salgamos a crecer imperfectos
[Música]